Scott Disick gets cozy in can with  another woman Kourtney Kardashian's ex  has been spotted hanging out and making  out with a few women while on vacay in  France including former fling Khloe  Bartoli and actress Bella Thorne I'm  trying to do everything I could do to  not think about her on Saturday Scott's  new interest seemed to be a friend of  the Kardashian family  Sofia Ricci the 18 year old model who  most recently was linked to Justin  Bieber was seen getting close to Scott  while on the same yacht as his former  flame Khloe who come to find out is  actually Sofia's stylist the two posted  plenty of snapchats together while  partying on the boat  I could Richie be Disick's new love  interest or are they just goofing around  for the cameras let us know your  thoughts over on Twitter at ET now  [Music]